[Musique]
quand même c'est prestigieux de menthe
rtt qui ça mais le plus prestigieux ses
portes que ce soit entre ses amis et
c'est grâce à vous que je suis sidéré
[Musique]
donc je suis heureux d'être parent
niveau ici à dans les autres cultures
farid ghazi qui en fait ce qui en fait
mourad ben ghazi le premier qui a eu le
doctorat en littérature en tunisie un
ami de jean paul sartre
donc il devait être avec nous au nom oui
non marabout félinoise mais non de cette
manière nous aurons 3 est parmi nous
donc pour vous dire que à travers
plusieurs valeureuse famille à jabba et
à travers ces valeureuses figure
emblématique sur les 16,6 à constituer
la mémoire collective d'allier qui est
devenu par la suite le patrimoine de
germaine donc mais le patrimoine bâti
vraiment laisse à désirer est-ce que
ce sera est ce que ce sera ça le
patrimoine de jobs ou bien ça le
patrimoine jamie cade architecture pour
demain en fait j'ai un ami qui me dit
souvent il ya une grande confusion entre
la valeur des richesses par exemple ce
bâtiment il a plu valeur mais cette
période richesse dans ça c'est une
richesse
cette architecture d'ateliers de 10,5
pour ceux qui possèdent encore des
ateliers et uniques par mois elle est
unique a dit eugène pas avec le système
de vous proposer
dénommé 20 juin le dos du dromadaire
avec ce système de de vous croiser et
unique
agenor ça c'est une autre richesse gêne
ceci n'est qui constitue un véritable
labyrinthe dans une logique de mode d'un
mode ingénieux d'occupation du sol et à
travers ses différents mazet de djerba
et les éléments culturels
bâti sur ligne donc bonheur il ya quand
même quelque chose d'exceptionnel sur
l'île de djerba et c'est ce que
nécessite vraiment le présent à l'unesco
donc le classement à l'unesco nécessite
cette valeur universelle exceptionnelle
et japan a de quoi être fier donc
l'unesco alors quand vous connaissez
tous prédit est inscrite sur la liste
indicative depuis 2012 notre espoir
c'est que ce projet permet et doit être
un levier de sauvegarde lit pour imposer
un plan d'aménagement d'unica ni de gêne
pas parce que l'actuel plan
d'aménagement de peine n'est pas
malheureusement la continuité de ce
paysage naturel de l'île de jeunes aussi
ça va être une reconnaissance auprès de
la communauté internationale de la
valeur de gerba et la valeur
exceptionnelle
bien sûr ce label prestigieux l'unesco
va faire un climat favorable à
l'investissement dans une logique de
développement durable et solidaire
cela me déçoit sur cette thématique
d'origine et culture et se fiance haye
il n'a jamais abouti un mariage
d'ailleurs qui fait la femme dans ce
mariage donc ça va être un pilier pour
créer une forme de tourisme responsable
et alternative à cet égard nous sommes
face à des statistiques alarmantes que
dans certaines régions de l'île ya plus
de juin ils sont dix ans pris les
bateaux comme al araji margalla et
plusieurs plusieurs régions dont de ce
fait nous devons et comme le thème de
l'événement d'antiques nous devons faire
de gerbe a eu lieu
de ce futur je vous présente cette cape
qui dette du 16e siècle cette cape de
djelfa et vous présenter quelques
phrases que je que je suis souvent et
qu' il est vrai que le monde est petit
mais sachez que dire par exemple grande
avec ses jeunes grands avec ses femmes
et grant avec tous ceux qui ont eu la
chance de goûter de son examen
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]